good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I
watch a lot of children's movies and I
watch the same ones over and over and
over again so today I want to review a
few from the perspective of an adult
let's begin with the lego movie a story
about overcoming the creativity stifling
and life-sucking power of big business
that was itself created by a very big
business not only that but it's
essentially a movie length commercial
for a different big business so Lego
movies relationship with corporate
America is just incredibly complicated
like the main character Emmett becomes
part of this team that saves the world
by building things as they go rather
than following the instructions but of
course these days Legos are all about
following instructions so it's kind of
making fun of Legos and then the Lego
store is now selling kits with
instructions on how to make the things
that the characters in the movie make on
the fly without instructions it's all
very meta hack and you could certainly
argue that corporate America is only
critiquing itself to make itself look
good so it can sell more goods and
services but whatever it as a fantastic
theme song the movie is totally
enjoyable so I forgive it everything
then there's the Croods which is a story
of cavemen Neanderthals who meet a human
and learn from that human the importance
of like innovation and risk-taking and
cooking your food over a fire the Croods
features a romance between a Neanderthal
teenage girl and a human teenage boy and
while interspecies romance is
disturbingly common in children's movies
it rarely involves like you know humans
then again most of us have some
Neanderthal DNA so there really was
human on Neanderthal action like sixty
thousand years ago so it's a historical
reality I'm just not used to children's
movies sharing the message that it's
okay for humans to fall in love with
organisms outside their own species said
there's Despicable Me 2 another favorite
of Henry's which is about a recently
retired supervillain who has gotten into
the jams and jellies business after
adopting three adorable children
the interesting thing about Despicable
Me 2 is that it's almost entirely about
adult problems like problems of
fatherhood and dating in middle age and
dealing with your tiny yellow minions
once you don't want to be evil anymore
but most of all it's about like romantic
love and that's a little weird because
like five-year-old kids don't get
romance but even Joe Henry loved it and
at the end he told me that he wanted to
marry mommy which I informed him was
illegal maybe you can date a Neanderthal
but you were not marrying
because that would be both bigamy and
incest lastly let's turn our attention
to Penguins of Madagascar which won my
heart
immediately because it begins with
voiceover from the great documentarian
Verner Hertzog Penguins of Madagascar
about this group of zany penguins who
break into Fort Knox because it contains
the last vending machine that sells
their favorite snack cheezy dibbles
Senna get caught up with this
shape-shifting villainous octopus named
Dave who is resentful because humans
have treated Dave poorly on account of
how he's not cute so Dave driven by
anger over not being cute has invented
this serum that turns penguins
monstrously ugly and therefore will make
humans uninterested in protecting them
so hang for at least the last 60 years
we've lived in a new geological period
the Anthropocene in which humans are
radically reshaping the planet we can
affect the atmosphere and the sea levels
in the planets overall level of
biodiversity and we can also choose
which animals to value and protect and
Dave the evil octopus is absolutely
right that we are very biased toward you
know the cute organisms so it seems to
me Penguins in Madagascar is really
about the Anthropocene as seen from a
nonhuman perspective which is totally
fascinating but unfortunately they cast
Dave as the villain so it ends up being
kind of a celebration of the cute
instead of a critique of our aesthetics
of cute still there's some really
interesting ideas there plus the
hilarious Verner Hertzog voiceover and
some top-notch cheezy dibbles oak so all
in all I give the movie a thumbs up so
Hank that some of what you've been
missing by not watching the same kids
movies over and over again human on
Neanderthal action business making
itself more likable by making fun of
business adult meditations on the
challenges of finding love in middle age
and a glimpse into the massive changes
wrought by the Anthropocene it's your
name The Kids Are Alright I'll see you
on Friday